[Music]
[Music]
today I'll stick to football it is time
we are breaking down the AFC South
grading those draft classes from the
best to the worst we're gonna run it
down
Matt Melo and Connor I apparently didn't
get the memo that today was Hawaii
five-o day it is 60 degrees and raining
outside I'm in a crewneck Melos in a
Hawaiian shirt
Connor is in a Hoboken where the weather
is beautiful I did not know it was
Hawaii Thursday we'll check my email
next week Monday when we come back 5
p.m. Eastern Time right here in the
Bleacher Report app I will be wardrobe
appropriate hook em horns so if you're
watching us in the B our app and
hopefully you are you can leave those
draft on traffic questions right here in
the comment section below
I know if you watched yesterday you like
see me type that's how you do it type of
type boys walk just show and have some
fun today it's good to be here oh it
always could be here you know in my mind
Matt it's sunny in 75 I was gonna say
being mellow or a dress it's a party and
hand out some grades here so let's get
it going yeah let's let's just jump
right in how about the Houston Texans a
team whose offseason we have ripped
apart like a t-bone steak after starving
to death Bill O'Brien has not done a
great job since being handed the reins
as general manager he trades away John
Trey Hopkins and basically gets back
nothing Melo you were gonna kick this
off force nobody no first-round pick
give us your grade and your thought on
the tie feel really bad for the Texans
fans I think I might feel worse for the
Texans fans than I do Packers fans this
is a degrade for me I like Blacklock and
I like the fit and this defense but I
don't think it's a huge need for the
Texas not with your very first pick in
this draft I feel like they could have
went somewhere else and they didn't
really pick up a whole lot jonathan
Greenert in the third round
I like that fit but again I don't know
that he's gonna come in he's gonna do a
lot for you you look at what these guys
are doing they're good players but you
probably should have done something else
and then you know bringing in David
Johnson maybe not the best move traded
away new cop khun's no I only was not a
good move so I'm sorry Texans fans I
love your quarterback and I hope you
guys are successful I just don't like
the moves here I'm going with Addie for
the Texans
maybe they can get that defense going
it's simply not been a good offseason
for the Texans I think you look at this
draft class it's obviously not the most
inspiring I really like Ross Blacklock
that's what kind of brings my grade up
from being the bottom of the barrel I
gave it a D as well here Melo I think
Blackhawks gonna be a good player for
them I do think it was a very obvious
need jonathan Greenert it's a guy that
can give you some pass rush off the edge
I thought they reached on Charlie heck I
thought they reached on John Reed I
think when you look at Isaiah Colter he
fits their size and speed demo of the
offense but overall when you look at
what they lost this offseason verse what
they gained in this trap this roster
unfortunately got worse now I'm a huge
deshaun Watson fan I want to see him
have a lot of success and listen this
was a playoff team last year there's no
doubt about that you're seeing it right
here that their defensive front should
be improved there is no denying that but
when you look at the decisions Bill
O'Brien has made while in charge of this
roster it's very very concerning for the
future of deshaun Watson and I hate to
sit here and just continue to kill the
Texans because it feels like that's what
we've done now for a couple months but I
don't know how anybody including their
fans I mean they're not idiots they are
probably going to agree it's it's brutal
to lose a guy like the andre hopkins and
really get no value in return so a
disappointing draft for the texans that
i have to give addy love Blacklock did
not like the rest of it at all guys
we've always said that Bill Belichick
the coach saves Bill Belichick the GM I
almost feel like Bill O'Brien's the same
way there's a good coach there's a good
team I think the Texans will be good
next year I just do not understand the
roster moves and with the NFL draft I
gave this team an F and I'm sorry again
I think we could talk about them maybe
still winning this division it's a great
team Deshawn Watson's gonna cover up a
lot of mistakes Laremy Tunsil is gonna
cover up a lot of mistakes but what
you've traded new cop khun's and got
back in return is abysmal and then to
not draft a running back you have Duke
Johnson who can't stay healthy and David
Johnson who can't stay healthy who's
gonna run the ball who's gonna catch the
ball out of the back but who's gonna
catch them all wolf Fuller has always
hurt Brandon cooks is is that gonna be
your guy concussions are an issue it's
like they don't even play
Matt what the injury setting turned off
here I like Isaiah Coulter as a date 3
player think yes good speedy has good
size down the field but it just felt
like a very cute draft where you go
after ok let's get a good D tackle like
you guys said I like Ross black like and
I like jonathan Greenert two good
players they were not priority positions
in my opinion I don't think so either I
think he had Charles a mini Hugh who
actually played pretty well yes you're
on that end spot and then who's that
other big guy they have JJ Watt that is
yeah the other guy that's gonna play
there I don't think you could put black
locket nose tackle and a hundred ninety
pounds message or either so yeah that's
why I kind of wait with a D on this
grade well let's move on to one of the
most surprising teams sorry Connor one
of the most surprising teams in the NFL
last year that was the Tennessee Titans
they came out of nowhere and started
smoking people after Ryan Tannehill was
put in a quarterback Derrick Henry
arguably the best running back in
football last year Mike Vrabel x'd
offense is very very good that crews
mostly back together Jack cockle and a
Logan Ryan the two big losses this
offseason fellows how about that great
and where you see the Titans you talk
about their two big losses they've
replaced those guys with their first two
picks I really like Isaiah Wilson out of
Georgia I think he's plug and play right
tackle he's probably one of the best
right tackles in this entire draft yeah
I think a lot of people will probably
say that was a reach in the first round
but I don't feel like it was I think he
would have been snatched up early in the
second and you get a first-round corner
in the second round and then Darius in
Heaven's a guy that we had on this
podcast I really like what he's gonna do
and how he's gonna pair with Derek Henry
I think he can take a little bit of the
pressure take a little bit of the
carries off of the big guy and also he's
gonna come in and be able to play some
special teams I really think that the
text the Titans here got a lot better
through the draft not a lot of teams
have been able to do that Tennessee was
definitely one of them though and I
think that they are probably in that
driver's seat in the AFC South now you
look at this guy who just moved people
now you're gonna get Derek Henry running
behind this big fella here very good
draft here I'm gonna give him a B+ they
didn't have a whole lot of pigs to work
with but I do like what they did in this
draft a rock-solid draft there's no
doubt about that when you look at them
they were never picking at the top of
round so it's not like they were working
with premium selections here guys
because
how good they were last year I like guys
a Wilson strictly as a right tackle
that's what they drafted him to be in
his the name of his game run blocking
he's so good at that he's so strong he
really with Makai Becton being in this
class it had somebody like Isiah Wilson
who's so physically overpowering get
overlooked at times and then when you
look at Christian Fulton falling that
far I think this is the defense that can
get him right but my favorite pick of
the bunch is Darrington Evans so you
know that late late in ninety third
overall pick right in the top 100 there
that's good value for a back that
complements Derrick Henry perfectly this
is a player that played in an outside
zone scheme in college a really good
vision really really good burst one of
the best NFL combines this year out of
the running back group he can catch the
ball so when you look at everything he
brings to their offense you aren't just
gonna drop back and hand Derrick Henry
the ball 40 times a game and you also
don't know if he's gonna be there after
this year so when you look at this
getting a guy that plays a totally
different style than Derrick Henry and
can potentially be your lead back down
the road not as a rookie but down the
road that's exciting to me with
Tennessee I thought they capitalized on
addressing needs while getting Pro ready
players across the first three rounds of
the draft and for me that's a rock-solid
V yeah I give them a B as well and my my
point was yeah they they did a great job
getting Isaiah Wilson in the first round
I think a month before the draft we all
would have said it's kind of a reach but
as the draft process played out we knew
I say Wilson was gonna be a first-round
pick T ain't Christian Bolton in the
second was an absolute steal and now you
have that versatility to take an already
strong defense and perhaps make it
better you could move a door Jackson
inside to the slot where his speed I
think is a benefit he can replace Logan
Ryan who still out there as a free agent
right now but getting Christian Bolton
who played through an ankle injury this
year that I think really affected his
game the toughness is there the
leadership is there and I thought he was
better than greedy Williams who was the
second-round pick in the 2019 draft so I
love that the Titans did that and then
to go to day three where they did not
have a lot of pigs
I thought they addressed some future
needs really well listen Ryan Tannehill
had a really good half a season last
year and we're all hoping that the
comeback is on I thought it was smart to
get a Cole McDonald just in case Ryan
Tannehill
isn't there we go it's the whole day
that's why you guys wore the Hawaii
shirts today now I get it but even your
little murchison in the fifth run you
trigger okay see it kind of a surprise
move a cap move and now you have a good
young backup defensive tackle you can
start working into that rotation so I
think John Robinson and Mike variable
have done a fantastic job of working
together to identify needs and also the
type of players who are gonna be a fit
for Mike Vrabel especially on defense
guys who are just gonna be tough
no-nonsense loved football even Chris
Jackson here they got in the seventh
round fits that mold so it was a really
really good draft by the Tennessee
Titans who know last year snuck in as a
wild-card team we're gonna get to our
individual winners a little bit later in
the show I have a feeling the Titans are
gonna be well represented here so Abby
for me and don't forget guys you can
leave your draft on draft questions
right here in the comment section if you
want to know anything weird a mellow get
that shirt how long is Connors hair
actually right now you can find out by
leaving a draft on draft question in the
comment section below and our producers
will give those to us today's show is
sponsored by our great friends at State
Farm State Farm offers home and auto
insurance you're covered whether you
live in a new age bond layer like Kliff
Kingsbury or a house made up of
discarded play cards like Matt naggy
good news if you're listening Jerry
Jones State Farm does offer yacht
insurance we looked it up so to all the
stickey's listening from their two
hundred fifty million dollar super
yachts like your good neighbor State
Farm will be there for you even when
you're deep into international waters
speaking of Bond villains goodness we
have no word on if State Farm covers Tom
Brady randomly walking into your Tampa
Bay mansion thinking it's Byron left
let's play left which is place but they
probably do thank you to state farms for
supporting stick to football what is
more Bond villain Kliff Kingsbury house
or Jerry Jones having a two hundred
fifty million dollar yeah I think it's
the yacht and that just screams Villa
yeah definitely alright let's keep
rolling on these AFC South traffic raids
you guys keep going with the comments
below us here Connor you get to kick us
off Chris Ballard's Indianapolis Colts
that's a lot of C's they bring in
Phillip Rivers at quarterback
no first-round pick they trade that for
DeForest Buckner how much better is this
team going to be and what did you think
their draft oh I absolutely loved it and
this team is gonna be a lot better guys
I mean the window or the competition got
super super tightness division really
because of what the Colts have done so
far you see the first two picks right
there Michael Pittman and Jonathan
Taylor
those guys are day one starters I had
first-round grades on both players I
think when you look at Pittman jr. his
ability to play above the rim will be so
important to an aging Philip Rivers who
really did struggle last year and you
watch Jonathan Taylor he's gonna get
more carries than Marlon Mac I think as
a rookie that's how Pro ready he is in
that power running style he has on that
offensive line and pivens ability to not
only win in the short area and
intermediate but down the field as well
is something that this offense has
lacked at the wide receiver to position
for so long right now you factor in that
they traded that first-round pick and
got the Horace Buckner for their
defensive line are you kidding me so
they added just in this draft guys
DeForest Buckner Michael Pittman and
Jonathan Taylor I think all three of
those players are gonna be Pro Bowlers
in the near future so when I look at the
Colts they got drastically better this
is an a-minus track for me we'll see
what they get out of the end of it it
was a lot of developmental picks down
the road but when you get that much star
talent with your first three selections
it's phenomenal phenomenal from Chris
Ballard and Ed Dodds
yeah I'm gonna steal you great I'm gonna
go a minus as well you talk about
Jonathan Taylor and what he did at
Wisconsin now he gets to do it behind
Quentin Nelson I can't wait to see this
happening all right I mean it's gonna be
very exciting to see those holes open up
and Jonathan Taylor burst through there
I like what they did though I think they
got immediate impact with Jonathan
Taylor I think this guy could come out
and be a Pro Bowler I think he can get
involved in the backfield catching the
ball too I mean I really love the fit
and what he's gonna do in Indianapolis
Colts fans should just be going out and
buying tailored jerseys right now I mean
he's gonna be one of the top running
backs in the NFL before too long but
then also you look at the other guys
they add I love the Jacob Eason pick
actually you get him later in the day I
think that he can sit behind rivers and
Brissette for a year and then maybe
start to learn how to be a professional
quarterback I think that's the fit
then a young guy like Issa needed and he
got it good fit for the Indianapolis
Colts I really like their draft I'm
going a - so I'm going a plus here's
what I do worry about Chad Kelly and
Jacob Eason in the same quarterback room
that's volatile but they did have a
great overall draft especially when you
factor in DeForest Buckner my favorite
player on my favorite team gets traded
this is like when PK Subban got traded
and I was depressed for a weekend I'm
still not over it DeForest Buckner I
mean he is an all-pro defensive tackle
and now they have that inside pass rush
might and again to look at Michael
Pittman jr. there there was an argument
for him to be a late first rounder
Jonathan Taylor there was an argument
for him to be a late first round kabisa
Jacob Eason there was not even for him
to be at least a second render this is
what Chris Ballard it feels like
consistently does Ballard and Ed Dodds
are exceptional in the scouting game and
I think that's what you see in their
later pics like Julian Blackmun if he
comes back from injury whether he's
playing safety or corner he's gonna be
an impact coming out of that Utah Utes
defense and a lot of the other guys
Robert Windsor anytime you watch the
Penn State this year it's like who's
that athletic defensive tackle like a
little undersized but he's pretty good
oh that's Robert Windsor he's gonna be
making place so have to love what
they've built on this team the key
though they're gonna be good this year
does Philip Rivers behind a better
offensive line plug in a higher level
they need you last year late for the LA
Chargers work
they almost benched him for Tyrod Taylor
so I'm a little bit skeptical how good
the team will actually be but they had a
great draft they get an A+ on my side
and things yeah kind of the Jacksonville
Jaguars they trade away Nick Foles they
have two first-round picks because the
Jalen Ramsay trade team had a tone of
needs but arguably I mean outside like
New England to Miami the most draft
capital of anyone this year and they
potentially did a really good job
filling those needs here guys when you
look at what Jacksonville did you get CJ
Henderson who for me was probably one of
the better athletes on the defensive
side of ball in this class I still think
the instincts are catching up so I
wasn't super high on taking CJ Henderson
in the top ten but he does protect as a
starting corner at the next level I love
Caleb on Chaisson I think he could do a
little bit of everything
whether it's rushing the passer whether
it's even covering outside run inside
run so to get him at the 20th overall
selection I valued him more than that
which made these picks kind of balance
out ylvis'
not guys that's what people are gonna
remember this trap fly in my opinion it
would be really shocking if guys like
Henderson and chase on bottom Allen
anyway you feel good about the floor of
those pics if should not can stay
healthy at 42 he is a steal in this
draft and a game-changer to make place
on offense but does do people believe he
can stay healthy that's the question
right now I thought there was a couple
reaches in here when you look at Devon
Hamilton does I Scott somebody that can
play in the slot but another player do
you do you think his size can convert at
the next level he has really really good
athleticism Colin Johnson in my opinion
was worth it on day three as a wide
receiver great catch radius in the
middle of the field so they did a lot of
nice things but there is risk in this
trap Shaq quarterman is somebody that's
he's a masher in the middle of the
defense he can't really run so what are
you getting out of him from the fourth
round they're their thing excite liked
about this Jacksonville draft some safe
picks early on a ton of risk with the
Chennault pick it's a B for me because
we won't look back at this trap and go
man that rebuild they got nothing but
the question is are they gonna get two
players out of this trapped are they
gonna get four because that's the kind
of thing that changes franchises year
after year yeah and I like this draft
I'm gonna go with a B+ I love the
Henderson pick I love that Chaisson fell
to them and I also like the guys that
they picked up later you get a Shane alt
who if he's helped it was one of my
favorite receivers going into this draft
class I think that he can be special and
on special teams as well Colin Johnson
the big receiver can pair with him and
what you already have there my big
takeaway for Jacksonville is you really
set yourself up for some future success
this is how you build the team don't
reach for a quarterback when you don't
need one sit around and wait I think
they're gonna be in a great position
next year with two first-round picks
again you get chase on off the edge with
Josh Allen that's gonna be at one heck
of a duo I like what they did here I'm
going b-plus for the Jaguars yeah I like
what Jax did as well I went b + CJ
Henderson was one of my favorite players
in the draft and Caleb on Chaisson was
probably my favorite player in the class
so they did a great job of going out
when you look at it you know an analyst
big Bourne sale they got a lot of your
top guys they did that this year they
absolutely did I do question a little
bit they didn't draft a quarterback
until the sixth round and I know
they may have struck gold when they did
that last year with Gardner Minshew I'm
a little bit skeptical only having
Gardner Minshew Joshua Dobbs and now
Jake Luton as your quarterback room I
don't know that that's good enough to
get it done as Melo said worst case
scenario you're gonna be bad and you got
two first-round picks next year and
there's a couple quarterbacks that
looked pretty good in college football
so maybe you're looking at it that way I
also think they did not address the
offensive line well enough
I don't think cam Robinson's the left
tackle and I know there was a little bit
of a run on that position I would have
given more consideration to go an
offensive tackle and trying to kick cam
Robinson in to guard or just moving on
from him after this upcoming season so
they're gonna have those two first-round
picks next year we could be looking at a
team that needs a wide receiver a lot of
their veterans are free agents hopefully
Chennault and Colin Johnson become
something but I don't know that this I'm
not ready to say the Jags roster is back
three years ago they're in the AFC
Championship game with a lead on the New
England Patriots this roster is
completely different than that team
completely different other than like
miles jacks so we'll see what happens
here with Jana Kukoc way I liked the
draft and just in terms of if you look
at the sheet all right these are our
draft picks we got you know CJ Henderson
Kayla van chase on Colin Johnson ylvis'
cachet no I thought they you know those
players are good I don't know that that
was exactly the biggest needs that this
team actually had but we'll see
hopefully gardner minshew
can continue to prove basically everyone
wrong because i don't know that anyone
thought that just one year later he
would be the franchise quarterback for
an NFL team we have to check out though
some gridiron hikes I am so excited for
what's coming down the road from these
guys with a new season hopefully upon us
but let's take a look at some running
backs that want to get paid okay running
back committee help yourself to
something I'm Jack that's a yards after
catch Joe
our q3 numbers are strong but cubies are
trending towards throwing the ball in q4
team now settle down yakking like real
receiver yeah what do I pay the beauty
guy like a million and this is why horny
guy works
I made less money and now play for the
Jetsons play for 40 years the chair
recognizes the Niners subcommittee deep
dive circle back synergy next order of
business how is chub growing uh dare the
haters say we suck just because we maybe
I'm the star fine rapid-fire ideas to
increase value go
we need cubies that don't do what we do
nose piercings arm tapes airheads war PM
should be dinner time not game time
all right gentlemen meet it adjourn why
does he get more pizza than me the same
amount of Pizza I just do more with it
[Music]
what's most shocking about that video is
how many of those running backs are on
those teams anymore like Todd Gurley
gone
Frank Frank Gore is amazing gone David
Johnson gone man you got a kid at plays
running back teaching and play safety
that's my life lesson how to - lets go
quickly around the horn pick those
division winners O'Connor gets to go
first today Connor who's your pick for
the AFC South in 2020 I'm gonna go with
the Colts here guys and Matt I don't
even think you know you're far off base
with that Philip Rivers did not look
like himself last year there's no
denying that we are really betting on
the offensive line and a power run game
and a lot of help at wide receiver and
tight ends and a really good play caller
in aiding him in these final years or
maybe even final years he's on that
one-year contract but I'm a big believer
in two things with the Colts number one
the run game is going to be phenomenal
two great running backs a good offensive
line a good play caller the other thing
is how improved this defense is gonna be
thanks to the one-man wrecking crew that
you know all about in DeForest Buckner
so it's a bit of a risky pick but I love
what the Colts have done and I think
they'll find a way to get the most out
of what Phillip Rivers has left yeah I
like what they're doing but ice I
watched the Titans run the ball and AFC
championship game and I really think
that that is going to be a good team
who's going to be I guess kind of sneaky
good we're a wildcard team last year I
think they could win this division sorry
Texans fans I don't think any of us are
gonna be picking you to repeat I almost
did I just literally was typing and
changed it was like I'm going with the
Titans I think the Texas will be right
there in the mix the Titans defense is
just way too good and when all else
fails give the ball the Derrick Henry
let him run behind I say at Wilson I
think that's gonna work pretty well for
them betting on Ryan Tannehill again
makes me nervous yes but I think you can
run the ball enough with Derek Henry
then it'll be okay in Jack em I got a
Jim Brown cannot forget AJ Brown there
all right let's get into some of these
draft on draft questions our first one
from Andrew c10 which rookie has the
biggest impact in year one in this
division so specific to the AFC South
Melo take it away
it's a no-brainer I really think this
guy's gonna rush for over a thousand
yards and 10 touchdowns and it's writing
more than Mack is still to go he is not
anymore
I don't think the Marlin Mack will be I
think that he's gonna be the change of
pace catch the ball the backfield guy
and Jonathan Taylor's gonna eat if
you're a fantasy odor
Jonathan Taylor's to get you but no if
it's not Jonathan Taylor then it's the
other guy they took in the second round
and Michael Pitts right all the targets
are there is somebody that will play
right away bet on the Colts offense when
you're looking at rookie production from
this division well I'll go outside the
box here I guess I think it's CJ
Henderson I think your corner corner can
be a tough transition so you got to
manage expectations a little bit but I
think CJ Henderson he'll be that number
one corner for the Jags he's gonna have
to face some very good receivers in this
division obviously but I think he's
gonna be able to step in with six one
two five four three speed he's gonna be
able to acclimate okay good enough to be
a big impact player here all right
second draft on draft question from our
guy Andrew Magnussen sticky of the year
this guy is this Cam Newton fit in
Jacksonville I don't see him winning
mini games with a quarterback room I
just said this of Gardner Minshew Josh
Dobbs and Jake Lou time mags you're the
man that's why you're so smart cuz we
agree all the time
I think Cam Newton does fit in
Jacksonville I don't I'm gonna disagree
and the reason why is because I think
they're gonna give Gardner Minshew the
ball I think they're gonna let him start
I don't think Cam Newton is coming into
that quarterback room and saying you're
not playing me just like Jordan that's
the hole I don't like George I actually
I don't like Gardner Minshew but I think
the organization is gonna give him the
ball and I think they're going to not
try to win football games this year and
that doesn't fit what Cam Newton wants
to do either I think if he's going
somewhere maybe it's like a Pittsburgh
where you can come in and be successful
there's no starting jobs out there
anymore I think if the Jaguars wanted
him to come in and start probably would
already kick the tires on now I think
they're gonna give the ball to Gardner
they're gonna lose a lot of games
they're gonna put themself in position
to get you know a trail answer Trevor
Lawrence next year in the draft I
counter Cam Newton did say today that
he's open to being a backup somewhere
you think he goes to Jacksonville and
tries to Ryan tan
way to a job it would surprise me if he
does end up there because I kind of tend
to aside with Melo that it seems like
they're handing the keys to Gardner now
what I will say is if Cam Newton found
his way onto that practice field and in
that quarterback room it's not a
conversation Cam Newton has more talent
in his pinky than anybody else in that
quarterback room it's not even close so
and I believe that Cam Newton is gonna
finally be healthy this year felt like
every time he got hurt at Carolina and
got no help from the referees in the NFL
with the late hits if like they were
just ending probably so Nvidia scam as
well we're putting them back on the
field and he kept taking those hits now
he said all of this time we're hey
there's a chance that this guy's healthy
this is an MVP caliber quarterback here
guys so I think wherever Cam Newton goes
the spotlight is going to be on him
because he's just he's too talented when
he's right so if I'm camp I don't blame
him for waiting it out seeing how the
situation plays out but if you're
looking at places where he can go in and
he's the most talented quarterback on
the field its Jacksonville it's New
England there's just not a lot of spots
man the charger I go
the newer Giants I'm just picking fights
without earlier today the quarterback
there yeah the Bears absolutely alright
last question from uncle Seb uncle Seb
since that happens frequently in the NFL
which team do you think has the best
chance to win its division in 2020 after
finishing last in 2019 well uncle said
the last place finishers last year kind
of sucked and so this is actually very
hard to do I let the other guys go first
today I set myself up perfectly here you
did I'm taking the Arizona Cardinals now
way out here way out on a limb
it was the Dolphins chargers Bengals
Jaguars Redskins Cardinals Lions
Panthers
none of those teams what I feel great
about saying yep it's them but I will
take the Cardinals because I love Kliff
Kingsbury can't believe I say this is
Burnett Texas shirt I love Tyler Murray
and now they have Isaiah Simmons and new
cop khun's Cardinals are gonna make
noise it's like I don't even know my own
brother anymore but I do agree with you
I would have picked the Arizona
Cardinals I think you're too with Kliff
Kingsbury could look
very differently and it wouldn't
surprise me if they did now at least
compete for the division now the rest of
these teams if you're making me pick one
I guess I'll say the Panthers if maybe
something happens to Drew Brees and he
suffers another injury if we don't see a
good Falcons team and maybe Tom Brady is
I don't there's no I can't make it work
to make it work maybe the Panthers and
some fantasy Joe Brady is just an elite
offensive coordinator and they'd set the
league on fire I don't know I don't love
any of these guys other than the
Cardinals those definitely would have
been my top two picks Arizona and then
the Panthers but about throw one more
into the bucket here guys just because I
think the vision is so wide open I think
it could be the Miami Dolphins
I really do I know that seems crazy to
say but there's somebody quite here's
the reason why when you look at the
teams they're playing in their division
we have three question marks at the
quarterback positions right now did Josh
Allen and Sam Darnell take some steps
forward last year yes but that Bills
team was really good around Allen he was
kind of there for the ride
Sam Darnell Ted a rollercoaster season
but some really nice stretches on a team
that wasn't very good and I think when
you look at New England we just simply
don't know what we're gonna see from
Jared Stidham last year we gonna see the
guy that had first-round expectations
before his final season at Auburn where
he didn't have a lot of help and then
goes in the fourth round are we gonna
see that guy I'm not really much a
believer as you guys but you never know
so I think when you look at Miami I love
to uh if it's magic has had these spurts
before where he goes on big winning
streaks they're a well coached team the
defense got an influx of money and draft
picks this offseason
Miami's at least interesting yeah
they're brown floor is one heck of a
coach I think we're all excited to see
that the AFC East is gonna be wide open
it's gonna be wild for sure
that is our show today that we'll be
back Monday same time 5 p.m. Eastern
same spot right here to be our app and
you can listen after the fact on Spotify
stitch
at the podcast wherever you get your
shows and you can check us out on
YouTube for everywhere
we're worldwide romelo and Connor on
that we'll see you all Monday 5 p.m.
Eastern right here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]